[Musique]
je me souviens c'est quand c'est
également pour scribouille est sur
toutes les voitures du garage de mon
père qu'on montrait que ceux qui
répandent des oreilles d'or comme lui et
lada les coster mon père me disait
toujours par être présent aux mondiaux
par edel
ça veut dire et comme un scientifique
figure j'ai pas sensé direct continue à
pisser sur les murs mon père ce qui
l'intéresse défendre les boulevards avec
son groupe et d'être sacré meilleur le
rider à elisa et lysiane parc des
centaines de clubs automobiles comme les
coster débarque de tout los angeles pour
devenir meilleur le rider quand on gagne
c'est comme devenir le roi de l'oat 10
ans une réputation de dinde
mais si on gagne pas c'est comme si on
n'avait jamais existé